is Islam a religion of peace or a
jihadist ideology that's a question
provoking sharp controversy here in
Germany since the right-wing populist
party AFD started wooing voters with the
message that Islam doesn't belong to
Germany it says that unlike Christianity
or Judaism Islam poses a threat to
democracy at first glance developments
in the Arab world might be seen as
supporting the claim for popular
movements there have largely been
stifled so how compatible are Islam and
democracy that's what we want to talk
about today on quadriga
with goodwin Cramer she teaches Islamic
Studies at Berlin's free University and
says it depends on how Muslims
understand and live Islam Muslims can be
good Democrats anti-power is a Berlin
based political scientist and an expert
on Islam
she says the recourse to religion is
often used to cover up simple power
interests this is true not only for
Islam but for other religions as well
and with Alan Posner who is a columnist
for the German newspaper developed he
says being religious means serving God
before the state and in this respect
Islam is no different from Judaism or
Christianity producer Cramer let's begin
by taking a look at what's driving the
AFD it won quite a bit of support in
regional elections recently with its
anti migration stance so is this latest
turn simply a further refinement of that
xenophobia well I think so to an extent
it's a it's a shift of focus I would
argue because the majority of refugees
that have come into the country over the
past few years are of Muslim creed and
religion but I think they also feed into
a widespread feeling of unease and
possibly even a sense of threat among
certain segments of the German
population and they're constantly
feeding into it I think adding to a very
very problematic atmosphere in the
country but the fact is Alan Posner the
number of migrants entering Germany
actually has been falling since some of
the initiatives that have been taken by
the government is this really then a
desperate ploy on the part of the AFD to
stay in the headlines no it's what they
realize is the more radical they get the
more they tap into the vast number of
people who haven't voted hitherto don't
vote who are dissatisfied with the
system as a whole and they take
xenophobia Islamophobia as a vent for
their dissatisfaction with the whole
parliamentary system so saying you know
that Islam is somehow undemocratic is
like the pot calling the kettle black
because what the AFD is after is
actually attacking the whole
parliamentary system as non
representative of what the people really
think populist parties everywhere at the
moment our job our are in revolt against
what they call political correctness is
that part of what this anti Islam talk
on the honor from the fafda is about
some somewhat yes because political
correctness was for example used last
year when there was a million of
refugees pouring into Germany
so what they see is that there's nobody
who is really defending occidental
interests or the interests of Germany
the rightists the extreme right wants to
have a strong Germany and so what they
say is somehow and to create a picture
which is to say all these ones they are
too soft and they are they are avoiding
Germany to develop and to have the
strength which they should have in the
world
so polls this week showed the AFD with
record numbers if an election were to be
held this coming weekend the AFD would
get 13.5 percent of the national vote
that's only about six percentage points
less than the junior partner in the
governing coalition the social democrats
that puts the AFD on a par with
established parties like the greens
goodwin claimer does that mean
people like this new message of anti
Islam it's very difficult to say I would
again come back to this word or term
rather of unease and and a latent sense
of threat that you fight among many
people who would not really vote right
wing if they were at the polling station
I would argue so yes its expressive of a
wider sense but it's also a conscious
urge to push people even further in this
direction now I would say that we're not
yet at the polling station we'll see
what comes over the next few months and
of course the other part is also very
active trying to fit the focus of
attention to other issues so as to sort
of take off some of the weight that's
been put recently on the question of
immigration and cultural cohesiveness
and authenticity etc when these identity
politics are extremely interesting and
of course we also have to look at the
contradictions between depicting German
values on the one hand and this claim to
be true to true Western values that they
are today is putting forth on posner
what do you think will the AFT win
points is it winning points with this
talk yes it is and it will it happens
it's happening all over Europe
and and it happened in the 1920's 1930's
the you know this this is what you do
you mobilize peoples and ease you turn
it into anger you direct that anger
against a part of the population be it
Jews be it Muslims be it whatever you
know who happened to be in the focus
it's easy they're different they're not
the same as us and and you use this for
completely different power political
ends and it works it works in France
with marine lepen it works in Poland for
the Kachinsky for mr. krichinsky
it works in Hungary for mr. Orban it
worked in the 30s for mr. Hitler and so
on and so on so this is you know I mean
this is you know this is just horrible
it's bad it's evil and evil works is it
so evil that the head of the
Central Council of Muslims here in
Germany is right when he compares this
talk on the part of the AFD to Nazism I
think this is this might be a little bit
exaggerated regarding the dimension
which it has right now in Germany but in
fact I think there's something coming
out which which we didn't see since
since 4050 years I think we see a part
of the society coming up coming up and
having a weight inside society which
they did not have before
maybe because they didn't speak out like
you said because they didn't vote I
think there's something else I think
this like a feeling of of parts of the
Germans right now that they don't
understand the world anymore that it's
not the world they used to know it has
become more complicated Germany has
taken a lot of years to understand that
it's migration country explain
especially the the right part of the
conservative part of the population try
to tune to deny that and to say okay
they will go back and so now it's the
point where they have to recognize there
are many people who come in from outside
and who have a different religion or
maybe a different culture and they come
here to stay and so I think what's going
on right now is also a lack of capacity
to adapt to a changing situation and to
understand that in a globalized world
things are different and Germany is
different that's a detailed description
of the unease that you talk about
professor Cramer do political elites get
that they have roundly condemned these
statements by the AFD are they doing
enough to reassure those who feel this
sense of unease well the thing is how do
you reassure someone who's seen or
phobic I mean how do you tell them that
the world is made up of different people
we're living in a globalized world
society will have to change and of
course I understand the
certain people don't see why they should
change simply because refugees come into
the country who they welcome but that's
that's life and I do not think you can
reassure them what you can do of course
is work on social policies and and
really do something against this within
the limits of the rule of law of course
against the violet expressions of
xenophobia justice you have to do
something against violent expressions of
Islamism which of course was slow to
happen but is to some degree now
happening with some prosecutions
speaking of political elites this latest
controversy of course arose in
connection with a draft party program by
the AFD in which it turns on its head a
formulation that had been used by a
former German president he said Islam
belongs to Germany the AFD says it's in
its party program Islam does not belong
to Germany the Chancellor has now
strongly reinforced that earlier message
let's take a look from my part I'd like
to repeat what former German President
Chris John both said Islam belongs to
Germany that's true I also hold that
opinion Islam does not it's not a part
of Germany but fully integrated Muslim
citizens they are part of Germany so
Alan Posner AFD leader talked up a tree
there the second half of that of those
two soundbite she didn't sound like the
neo-nazi she's often portrayed to be
fully integrated Muslim citizens are
part of Germany what's to object to
there well the first thing the first
part of your question was does she sound
like a neo-nazi no of course he doesn't
but first she isn't a neo-nazi
but she is a racist she's the leader of
a party which is going for racism
evermore the point is we're all waiting
for people to run around with skinheads
going like this that's you know that's
been proved not to work now it's you
know the the softer approach and the
second thing is yes what does it mean
fully integrated Muslims am i a fully
integrated Muslim if I demand that the
school where my with my daughter attends
they serve her on meals I think I am I'm
it's my right within a democracy but
foot but you know there have been
attempts to force schools to serve pork
in in Germany in order to exclude these
people so I mean where what do you mean
by fully integrated and and this is you
know this is this is the kind of soft
talk that the you know in the end the
point is to say they can't be fully
integrated because their religion isn't
going to allow them that anti power up
to five percent of the German population
is Muslim figures aren't quite clear but
up to five percent not a negligible
number would you say most of us would
meet for Alka Patrese criteria of being
fully integrated yeah I think that's
what you said the question is what do
you call fully integrated do young women
Muslim women who wear a scarf are they
fully integrated because for the AFT
they are not because they DFT asked them
to push away not to use the headscarf so
the question is the definition it I
think it is clearly I think the the
authorities talk about a thousand people
who are terrorists or would-be
terrorists possible terrorists and all
the others are not obviously and most of
the Muslims here in Germany even don't
go to the mosque they don't even pray
but I think it's not our our deal to
talk about this to they pray or do they
go to the mosque I don't care about with
if my so-called Christian neighbor goes
to the church or not
that is their private thing as long as
they stuck to our constitution and they
and they they live peacefully that is
what this the big majority of them do I
don't have a problem with them look at
this draft program of the AFD does
indicate some of the points that it
might expect fully integrated Muslims to
give up
professor Cramer it would ban the call
of them whizzin it would ban minarets on
mosques it would ban the public wearing
of both the burqa and the knee hub isn't
that at some point tantamount to banning
the religion itself not necessarily
because according
to Muslim theologians and lawyers you
can practice Islam without those
elements but that is a minority position
that's not really representative and I
would argue that the problem is that
this position stands in conflict with
the German constitution because we are a
secular country with a freedom of
religion within the bounds of legal
requirements and there's nothing in the
Constitution that bans the wearing of
the headscarf would that would be my
position you can argue about the
full-body veil because that is a
different matter altogether but I do not
see how constitutionally you can defend
the ban on minarets you might argue that
when the Malaysian really disturbs the
public peace and it prevents people from
sleeping at cetera there might be a
limit to that but that's not what
they're talking about they try to make
Islam invisible and to ban any
expression of Muslim affiliation and
that is a problem and it does not go
together with our laws Alain Posner the
AFD s draft program appears to want to
make a distinction between Orthodox
Islam and other forms of Islam and it
claims that Orthodox Islam is not a
religion but a political program
quote/unquote would you say that that's
true if not for moderate Muslims then
perhaps for fundamentalists in other
words does Islam lead directly to
theocracy if you take it at its most
fundamental yeah every religion leads to
theocracy if you take it as its most
fundamental so does Catholicism so does
Protestantism we've had Protestant
theocracies for instance in Geneva in
Switzerland where by the way minarets
are banned today we've had the Pope was
a theocratic and till the end of the
19th century we've we've had you know we
have theocratic communities like the
Mormons in the United States of America
we've had we you know parts of Jerusalem
you try and drive a car Friday evening
during it stones thrown you're a Jew
because it's it's Shabbat so yes there
is a tendency in all religions and of
course within East
to create theocracy it's the it's the
it's the job of moderate people within
these religions and the job of moderate
States to curb that the point is that
within the Islamic world there are no
such thing as moderate States not
because of Islam but because these
generals dictators of all sorts have
been oppressing the majority of the
people ever since came out Ataturk
actually and have forced Islam into
opposition which radicalizes people as
we know Jabbar you also said in your
opening statement as did Alan Posner
that in the end there really isn't that
much difference between the various
religion when it religious when it comes
to politics and the potential for
violence but is that really true the
Bible for example contains potential
exportations to violence but in fact few
Christians today even the most
fundamental would ready and be ready to
gird their loins and march into holy war
yeah but the question is how you live
this I think the the the important point
here is well how is the the influence of
religion on the state where you live in
so I think that is the important point
as long as you have a secular state
where people abide to the state's laws
the the role of religion is something
with which goes back to private life so
and in the moment in in which there's a
conflict between religion and the state
obviously is that it is the state law
which is which is the important one so I
think that that makes difference in the
end and you have you said that the Kemal
atatürk was authoritarian I agree to
this he was but he he was a sort of
model it was an approach top-down but he
was a sort of model who try who try to
make a secular state work in in Muslim
state with a long Muslim history and I
think there were some things which
worked out alphabetization education
they have something they have a core of
democratic values I think it can work
but the point is that you have to kick
religion out what they are
now religion right now in Turkey is that
religion is coming more and more back so
what you come back to the Turkish
example in a moment let me ask you this
professor Cramer staying with the
question of theology one Muslim
intellectuals said after the 9/11
attacks on New York that although no by
no means every Muslim is a terrorist
most terrorists at the moment our
Muslims is that link a theological link
or a political link what's going on it's
usually very difficult to sort of
clearly sort out whether something is
purely religious or purely political and
I would think that there's a whole
combination of factors that have led to
that statement and it is correct but if
we look at the present situation the
majority of terrorists are Muslims and
claimed to act in the name of Islam but
the problem lies in in the
generalization that you say because that
is the fact now it has to be like that
and it's within religion the Quran tells
them to do that and they only act and
follow those injunctions that is where
the problem resides and the the
imperative really is to deal with the
militant Islamists rather than
speculating about the evil and violent
violent nature of Islam as such which
makes it impossible for Western
societies to live in peace with their
Muslim citizens because if you
constantly tell them that they are the
same as the militants how should they
act how should they be part of society
if they are under this constant cloud of
suspicion let's look beyond Western
societies now because when we take a
look at the Arab world it is the case
that popular democratic movements there
appear to be in retreat Tahrir Square in
Cairo the beginning of 2011 hopes for
real democracy in Egypt flourished a
revolution toppled the government of
dictator Hosni Mubarak
in the country's first freely contested
elections the Islamic Brotherhood took
power but the movement didn't hold it
for long after months of turmoil a coup
d'état led by Abdel Fattah el-sisi
the former generals later became
president in disputed elections since
then both the military and police have
cracked down on opposition even more
than during the Mubarak era despite that
many Egyptians accept the autocratic
regime if el Sisi were toppled they fear
the country could descend into chaos are
the events in Egypt evidence that
Western democratic principles simply
don't fit in the Arab world
al Jabar why did the Arab Spring fail to
produce a democratic summer is Islam
somehow not fertile soil for those
Democratic seeds that were sown there I
don't know if Islam is the problem I
think you had on one hand you had
Islamic parties who said they they did
politics in the name of Islam in fact it
was a power play and they didn't want to
share they were in the tradition of the
dictatorship like the dictators were
being forced to leave so in most of the
countries the people who did not agree
to them they thought the only
alternative is the other side that is
why we have this flashback line what we
see in Egypt and I think that's the
problem we have come to to the old
polarization between the so-called
secular elite which has established a
dictatorship before and is establishing
a dictatorship right now here or in
Yemen same thing and Iraq the situation
is different but it's also along these
lines of power play in the end and
religion is being used for this the one
country that's often held up as a
counterexample of course Tunisia
professor Kramer how stable is democracy
they're impossible to say because it's I
would I would fully agree what Boris
just said it's I would not look at
religion as the decisive element here I
would look at the very complicated
mixture of economic problems and power
politics and the fight between elites
because they're also Muslim elites or
Islamist elites in in these countries so
it's not just one side only so Tunisia
will succeed if it solves some of the
economic problems and if it's not
swamped and sort of completely absorbed
with this refugee wave and the counter
policies it's small it's off some of the
major conflict points that's in its
favor but it would have to deal with the
economy and if that does not succeed it
will not be a question of
Lahm or not it will not be a very
prosperous society let's put it that way
this the interesting thing is that
Tunisia has sent the in numbers there in
concrete numbers the maximum of people
to the Islamic so-called Islamic state
but they nearly all come from the
internal parts of the country which is
much less developed where the young
people have no perspective whatsoever
and so that is different something where
they go where they can identify
themselves where they get money from and
Glory's story yeah Alan Posner of the
negative examples don't only come from
the Arab world Turkey was mentioned as a
positive example but the fact is
democracy is looking pretty embattled
there as well Chucky's well the rock is
always embattled its embattled in
Ukraine
it's not even existent in Russia which
is a Western country not existent in
wide Russia look at Spain Greece a
couple of decades ago come on I mean
this is not a specific problem and if it
is a specific problem of the Arab world
it has to do with the fact that all
these countries Egypt Syria Iraq were
basically socialist countries with the
state owned everything elite controlled
the state if the masses didn't have
anything there was no such thing as a
bourgeoisie a middle class which is the
pillar of democracy and it emerges that
this middle class is often turns to
Islam as a vehicle for gaining power as
they have done as the a.k part is done
in Turkey and if we clamp down on that
and side with the elites who we call
secular who in just prep just as
repressive as anything we know from our
own history then we're making a huge
mistake because we have to you know I'm
not sure that you know the Muslim
Brotherhood is a partnership anymore a
partner anymore but they could have been
if we turn to them in time we have to
realize did you the more you oppress a
religion and a group of people they're
more they're going to radicalize this is
what has happened
professor Cramer just a couple of
sentences Islam and democracy how do we
make them a better fit you can you can
invite Muslims and listen to them and
ask them about their ideas of good
society and good governance and what you
what you'll hear is the rule of law
transparency and perhaps even democracy
not necessarily so it's not Islam its
Muslims thank you very very much
thanks to you out there for joining in
and hope to see you soon